organic food is no longer a niche market
[Applause]
in just 10 years sales of organic food
in the eu have more than doubled from
16.3 billion euros in 2008 to 37.4
billion euros in 2018. but while we're
buying more and more organic at the
grocery store do we even know what food
manufacturers actually mean by organic
[Music]
is an overall system of farming
management and food production that
combines best environmental practices
a higher level of biodiversity the
preservation of natural resources the
use of higher animal welfare standards
and the use of natural substances and
processes
great let's break it down then starting
with food crops
[Applause]
conventional farming uses lots of
nitrogen phosphorus and potassium-based
fertilizers on organic farms food is
grown with natural fertilizers such as
compost and seaweed products
farms need to keep weeds and bugs off
their crops normally they'll use
synthetic pesticides such as glyphosate
and prosulfocarb but in order to be
certified as organic in the eu farmers
have to stop using those pesticides use
natural techniques such as crop rotation
and predatory insects like ladybugs and
naturally derived pesticides made from
plants animals microorganisms or
minerals
it's important to remember though that
just because something is natural it
doesn't automatically make it harmless
to either people or the environment
to be certified organic your food cannot
contain products made from genetically
modified crops when it comes to organic
meat and other animal products the
animals are to be raised on 100 organic
feed
the animals we eat or whose products we
consume need to be kept disease free
if in a
conventional
sometimes antibiotics are given as a
present preventive tools in organics
antibiotics can be given as a last
resort if there are no other methods to
intervene normally the the
higher animal welfare standards applied
in organics
already keep animals in a healthier
status that prevent the use of
antibiotics
excessive antibiotics are not good for
people or animals because they can
create resistant germs or superbugs
the eu sees around 33 000 deaths related
to antimicrobial resistance every year
finally
organic livestock must have access to
the outdoors this isn't compulsory in
conventional farming
now all of these are just some of the
requirements the eu has a whopping
84-page report that explains organic
food rules
so that's what organic food is
now here's what organic food isn't
organic doesn't mean locally grown
europeans are the second largest
consumers of organic products in the
world local supply can't meet demand yet
so a large number of organic products
are imported
natural green or eco doesn't mean a
product is organic
and organic also doesn't necessarily
mean that a product is good for you
if you see this logo it means it's
certified as organic in the eu
that means eu rules have been followed
in its production processing handling
and distribution and that it contains at
least 95 organic ingredients
these rules are the same for all member
states
but these rules will change soon
in 2022 we'll have legislation with
stricter controls
non-eu and eu producers will have to
respect the same rules
and europe will have some new ambitious
targets as part of its farm to fork
strategy
by 2030 the eu wants to reduce the use
and risk of harmful chemicals and
hazardous pesticides by 50
and by the same year 25
of all eu farmland is to be dedicated to
organic farming
in 2019 it was only around 8
the eu's farm to fork strategy aims to
make healthy sustainable food more
accessible and affordable to all
europeans
because buying organic food is still too
expensive for many
organic farming is far from perfect but
many experts agree that if we develop
new techniques and manage food waste
better organic farming could provide the
entire world with better food in the
future
the future of organic farming looks
definitely very bright bright
surfaces in europe are increasing or as
well as all over the world and they are
increasing at a fast pace it's
undoubtedly a very ambitious target but
surely feasible
[Applause]